puis environ six ans il y à une
manipulation de l'information il y avait
vraiment des personnes qui sont toujours
les mêmes et qui sont très minoritaires
qui ont porté des informations erronées
devant la presse au grand public donc
aujourd'hui il est de notre devoir
devant le danger grave qui menace leur
la matinée il nous faut réagir
aujourd'hui parce que cette université
ne sera pas viable parce qu'elle va
disparaître rapidement parce que une
masse d'enseignants chercheurs vont par
action
une masse d'étudiants aussi vont partir
parce que les familles n'ont pas
confiance et parce que les diplômes ne
sont ni aucune validité quand on est une
petite université aussi faible on ne
peut pas avoir au rayonnement
international on ne peut pas avoir une
viabilité
on ne peut pas être entendue donc pour
nous enseignants chercheurs ce ne sera
pas acceptable dont beaucoup
d'enseignants chercheurs vont vont
partir à l'osq ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui je lance un appel vraiment à
tout le monde aux parlementaires à tous
les martiniquais conscient à tous les
maires pour qu'ils nous rejoignent
nous les martiniquais conscient des
personnes des adultes responsables des
parents des parents de deux jeunes et
des martiniquais qui veulent que la
menthe unique demeure un pays attractif
voilà que qu'il nous rejoigne dans une
comité de défense de l'université des
antilles si cette université disparaît
nous sommes dans un danger très grave
danger de considération de notre société
notre société va s'étioler
nous allons nous allons en souffrir
gravement pas seulement la jeunesse mais
je pense tout cette société donc je fais
un appel vraiment à toutes ces personnes
pour qu'elle nous rejoigne dans un
comité de défense et qu'elles aillent
tous les parlementaires tous les
meilleurs
toutes les personnes qui ont une
autorité qui ont point dans cette
société et qu'elles aillent nous
représenter et expliquer au gouvernement
français explique hamas à monsieur
macron que nous ne voulons pas de cette
scission qu'il est très important pour
nous de garder l'université des antilles